Mais une autre réalisation plus prononcée qui ressort
est la trivialité de notre suffisance et de notre conscience de nous-même.
Vraiment comprendre à quel point votre conscience de vous-même
vous empêche de saisir des opportunités
devrait pousser tout le monde à prendre des risques
qu'ils ne prendraient pas autrement.
Nous ne sommes qu'un soupir sur la ligne temporelle de l'univers.
Agissez en conséquence.
Les idées que je présente aujourd'hui m'ont été inculquées
dans des circonstances par ailleurs regrettables,
mais elles sommeillent dans la vie de quiconque est prêt à les exploiter.
Si nous comprenons tous que nous avons des faiblesses uniques
et si nous sommes honnêtes sur ce qu'elles sont,
nous pouvons apprendre à en tirer avantage au mieux,
que ce soit monter sur un trottoir, craindre de présenter un rapport de ventes
ou être incapable de bien gérer ses finances --
je regarde ce gars-là --
(Rires)
il y a là la capacité à apprendre, à s'adapter
et même à recâbler sa réponse instinctive face aux défis.
L'adversité est une bonne chose
et elle a le potentiel de vous rendre plus fort.
Au minimum,
vous pouvez effrayer les enfants si vous ressemblez à un pirate.
Merci.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)